très grosses innovation on va venir
imprimer sur les dalles OLED au niveau
des téléviseurs c'est TCL qui monte ça
aujourd'hui vous connaissez la dalle
OLED il y a en plus le quantum d'hôtes
au LED le qd au lait qu'on retrouve
notamment chez Samsung c'est-à-dire que
vous avez une DALO LED et devant on
vient poser un film quantum d'autres et
là on va aller beaucoup plus loin
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait vous allez avoir
une impression de phosphore RGB red
green blue le rouge bleu vert sur un
panneau OLED alors ici sur des
prototypes que nous montre TCL ça monte
là où on va aller au niveau des dalles
OLED permettra d'avoir une meilleure
luminosité meilleure colorimétrie et on
peut s'en parler sur des formats qui
vont être assez petit notamment du 17
pouces et aller sur du 140 pouces
au-delà et même bien plus donc ça c'est
assez marrant alors c'est des choses qui
pourront arriver en 2024 sur les lignes
d'assemblage et des premiers produits
qu'on pourrait voir arriver à l'horizon
2025 qui est super c'est qu'ici sur un
salon comme le ces on vient voir ses
techno en avant-première est-ce que ça
pourrait vous tenter ce que vous êtes
curieux de découvrir cette technologie
d'impression sur une dalle OLED oui non
quoi comment vous marquez ça dans les
commentaires et moi je trouve ça
absolument fabuleux